[Music]
hey every day we're gonna talk about
Missy Elliott's funky white sister we're
gonna talk about Spotify his most
streamed songs of all time but first
watch this it's a sneak peek from
tonight's episode of South Park mr.
hankey 14 years ago did you or did you
not say everyone in South Park is a
goddamn douche pack yes that was a bad
attempt at a Christmas joke but there's
nothing in that statement about
Christmas that's what I say it was a bad
attempt what part of the statement was
act you want to hear a good Christmas
joke
in 2005 you said you said that you had
no recollection of them sorry I got the
Schnee loss okay so that's right
tonight's episode the name of the
episode is the problem with Appu what do
you think that could possibly be
referring to or commenting I don't know
but it sure is such a subtle way of
calling someone a piece of I think
he's too cute though he's like a too
cute piece of
I like how everybody lands he leaves a
little little state it's very dark
though you think about it because it's
like a piece of his body is like left
everywhere he goes so he would run out
at some point
that's what I always thought like when I
was watching as a kid I was always like
oh my gosh this guy's like slowly gonna
turn into like the kids would get older
- yeah but they did go - from 3rd to 4th
grade
[Laughter]
the problem with Appu that's like it's
like a reference to the Hari Kondabolu
nobody's safe stop comment I'm like
outraged culture in general oh yeah of
course
that clip I can't wait I hope will be a
cartoon Alyssa Milano be a pair of boobs
great eyes and opinions Network called
Comedy Central check it out I want to
move on to the next story this is from
the American Music Awards Twitter loses
control after spotting Missy Elliott's
funky white sister this is of course if
you're not familiar Joe check out that
next gif
ok so I like the double gift so that's
Missy singing and dancing with tiara and
then in the audience is funky white
sister Mary there's a bit of backstory
you might need
surely Mary's famous very famous
apparently and she's famous because she
did this is the strangest Trump rally
I'd ever just nice to see that like old
ladies rapping is still fun for
everybody
you know today's America that it still
works there's some things that can cut
across party lines she might be my aunt
like well my aunt likes a song he just
gets it in you can't stop her yeah I had
a dinner party I know what I move that
neck my mom loves to sing along to music
too but she's usually off on the lyrics
she doesn't look into the lyrics and
find out what they are just not checking
out checking out lyric genius well cuz
she doesn't even a censor herself she
just funky white sister the video in its
entirety is a gem so get out watch it I
don't know if you guys made it to the
end but there it so the woman who was in
the foreground for a second she makes an
appearance at the end she comes behind
the woman and is just going in front of
like honda to a car commercial like i
have a week she's holding it what it
looks like is a shofar which is it's a
ram's horn that is used like during
jewish services for yom kippur and Rosh
Hashanah they brought her on to Ellen
they gave her that so she's like holding
the big ram's horn while wrapping and
then the surprise is that Missy Elliott
comes out and she's like oh my gosh this
is great and then she just goes back to
wrap it like she she like finishes it
because she blew it on Ellen tushy
it's like it's like her version of them
[Music]
this is just 1 million I did a cover of
Kanye's wet Kanye West stronger at my
high school and I didn't get for me
I get on Ellen I can get Kanye I didn't
even record it and put it somewhere yep
it's on YouTube and you put it on
YouTube we were trying really hard
she's a natural this Marietta we killed
in the audience and we got booked to do
other shows but those didn't go well at
all yeah we did other high schools there
did other high schools like townships it
was weird
that's some level of him I was like yo
this is this is gonna be it right like
you think did they did someone think
that one of you is dying and it's like a
make-a-wish let's keep the music chat
going throw up that next headline
Spotify unveils its most streams artists
songs and albums ever this month was the
10 year anniversary of Spotify we've all
been using it for 10 years
any guesses with the most streamed
artist of all time one Drake the top
artists were Drake ed Sheeran mmm any
surprises there
and he had the number one most streamed
song also there's this DJ DJ snake this
French guy who is done yeah you know him
however he's I think maybe one of two
people who have ever hit a billion
streams on two separate songs oh yeah he
had he had the Justin Bieber song let me
love you 2016
and then this other one leaned on that's
in like I think a commercial or
something
he's not on I don't know why he's not in
list but he said he's I guess he's only
had two songs that have hit a billion so
he didn't like crack the top ten but
he's like lower than like Calvin Harris
and the Scottish guy and imagine like
being a billionaire still not being on a
top list of my dreams like that you feel
asleep I'm a billion I should be in the
list cow and that's what's so weird now
is like it's hard enough to keep up with
who the popular artists are now there's
producers that are famous sure everybody
gets famous that even marry well she
deserved it is moment yeah I don't think
it's Ellen I'll say I have cancer I have
to break it to our audience have a shout
out for me I have a shout out Thank You
Hannah yesterday we talked about
drinking games obviously I knew the most
fun game which would slap the bag and
chick boskie said the cash should play
slap the bag on the next episode and I
deliver and the real game is you have to
guess if this is what type of wine is it
or is it Nate Spitz how do I do it
whoever has the largest come on over
chugs the longest
[Laughter]
[Applause]
five second this is for you - well
thanks for shout out Hannah we're gonna
do something different right now okay
but bigger than you think
great okay hi I'm YouTube's Jordan
Mendoza
I'm comedian and sometimes stock footage
director you know stopped footage videos
that website sell to company is new
stations or anyone that's too lazy to
shoot it themselves today I'm gonna give
you a behind-the-scenes look at my
process directing stock footage actors
action ok David yeah for this one just
swing your sword but be totally unsure
about it almost like your Viking who has
never held a weapon in his life oh yeah
ok good job awesome alright for this
next one just do something freaky with
your pecs oh my god perfect family
looking good okay I don't actually know
what I was doing going forward this one
maybe lower your weapons at once and
wonder why we're doing this at all
alright
[Music]
epiphany a moment when you suddenly
become conscious of something that is
very important a suit raises your
credibility cracks diminish your
credibility but weighing them together
makes you a CEO that was an epiphany in
history at work I don't know what you
guys were doing I stopped I had to go
but if I wouldn't win first I would work
for like 30 second who goes last always
wins because they're like just two more
[Laughter]
yeah I didn't know what the bar was five
seconds everyone is screaming at me look
it's important to drink responsibly it's
also important to stay safe from germs
and it's important to register to vote
so make sure to go ahead and do that
this week and I wouldn't be telling you
this if it weren't for me having
previously chugged wine for five seconds
make sure to register to vote that
cutoff for lots of states is Friday so
you know don't be a piece of don't
be
[Music]